no they don't uh firstly you need to ask
this question why is the question of
refugees important now why not when
gutterings of buying errors
why not when qataries and investing 20
of the stake in Heathrow Airport why not
when qataris are buying chunks in
Barclays Bank okay why don't you ask
these questions when these these
contracts are being signed multi-billion
dollars or multi-billion pound contracts
I mean why not when cutlies have the
largest
land owning profile in Britain they are
the largest land owners to my knowledge
okay they probably own More Country
business entities own more land in
Britain than the royal family now I
think all right so when these contracts
are being signed so be morally
consistent then right ask this question
then number one number two
when did any of the Muslim countries
claim perfection
we've never claimed superiority over
other civilizations we don't what we do
claim is religious superiority We
Believe Islam is the best solution to
humanity or for Humanity okay we stand
by that claim but Muslims are not the
best examples we make it very clear
countries people tribes Nations they're
not the best examples they have their
Traditions they have their ways of doing
things
when you say what makes them better not
best what makes them better is Islam and
where they are lacking is because they
are ignoring that aspect of Islam
because Islam is very clear on kindness
on compassion on generosity on
Hospitality on things like that Trump is
very clear if a people or if a tribe is
not practicing that
particular aspect on Islam this is what
we need to talk about secondly they
don't have the moral High Ground
people who ask you this question they
created millions of refugees in the
Middle East and abandoned them I say
that yeah okay
I'm not gonna blame them for Syria but
Iraq
come on guys be be serious about it when
you have a conversation we need to talk
about this we need to actually raise
these questions that when did Qatar
invade another country and leave
millions of refugees and walk away
it's the question right in fact a
country like Qatar is health
Health work here
right these are people from very poor
countries they are living in utter
poverty they want to come here and work
right but there's no Perfection and and
it's a country which which wants to get
better I mean I'm talking and now it
sound like a spokesperson
but I've been watching interviews I've
been watching interviews right I watched
this very good interview by this uh this
person who was responsible for the world
cup
says Morgan he did a very good job he
said look we have things to improve we
are improving we're not saying we're not
going to improve we're not being out of
it we're not telling you to get lost yes
we have things to do we are we are
things to improve like any Nation like
any people we're getting there so we
don't need to be on the back foot okay
when people question you need to raise
all these points why now it is the World
Cup that is burning you for some reason
yes yeah it's really you know we can
hear the sizzling sound and we can see
the smoke coming from all over the world
what the hell is wrong with you people
you can't you know
Quran is so amazing how Allah revealed
that these people will never be happy
with you oh when something good comes to
you for Allah they're not happy
right so this is this is we again we
need to be as assertive as we can be as
confident as we can be we acknowledge
thoughts where they do exist and then
then we we express the beauty of Islam
and tell them this is not because of
Islam because of our lack of Islam